la pulverizada mariupol parece un pueblo
fantasma pudimos entrar en una parte de
la ciudad donde fuimos escoltados por
fuerzas rusas y separatistas ahora
tienen el control aquí ninguna casa o
edificio parece haberse librado del
fuego cruzado en las calles vacías
algunos residentes deambulan
desorientados como este hombre con la
cara cubierta de hollín
a dónde vas vuelvo a mi casa
pero allí no queda ninguna casa
todavía queda es el vecino
parece que ya no oye los bombardeos en
la distancia
la electricidad la calefacción y el agua
están guardadas desde hace casi un mes
los que quedan como oksana viven
hacinados en el subsuelo
ahora somos 50 personas los bombardeos
dan mucho miedo las condiciones de vida
son nefastas hay polvo por todas partes
las mujeres y los niños duermen en estos
colchones habían días en los que no
teníamos nada que comer dábamos a los
niños galletas o lo que tuviéramos ahora
el frente se ha movido podemos salir
pero solo para cocinar
un poco más lejos de donde se refugia
oksana esto es lo que queda del teatro
de mariupol fue aquí en el sótano donde
se refugiaron varios cientos de civiles
estas imágenes fueron tomadas por un
canal de televisión ruso no muestra
ningún cuerpo dentro de lo que queda del
edificio donde se teme que murieron 300
personas en un solo ataque ruso cerca de
una de las salidas de la ciudad los
residentes huyen de la devastación los
soldados separatistas registran a todos
los que salen los hombres deben quitarse
las camisas esto es para demostrar que
no están luchando por ucrania es para
que los ss no huyan todos los de los
batallones ultranacionalistas tienen
tatuajes de las ss familias enteras se
van muchas de ellas con lo poco que aún
tienen y estoy muy cansado y mis
juguetes no tienen batería las ventanas
de nuestra casa explotaron
y en casa de los abuelos y de mi amigo
el apartamento se quemó todo se quemó
[Música]
la casa de esta mujer también se quemó
nos cuenta que se lleva todo lo que le
queda